48 heures après la catastrophe de key
west les enquêteurs sont toujours à pied
d'oeuvre autour du boeing et milan 0 1
on sait désormais avec certitude que le
moteur droit a bien été coupée aucune
trace d'un incendie n'a été retrouvée
sur ce réacteur
si l'on ne connaît pas la cause de cette
coupure en revanche on n'est pas loin de
penser qu'elle aurait pu avoir lieu non
pas quelques secondes avant l'accident
mais entre londres et belfast est en
position de pousser zéro c'est à dire de
moteur coupé nous avons l'instant parler
d'erreur de pilotage
on reste également très prudent du côté
de la snecma
il y a sont ils actuellement une
certitude c'est qu'il y a effectivement
lui un problème
initialement mineurs son hôte sur un
moteur que s'est-il passé ensuite je
n'ai pas d'éléments pour pouvoir porter
un jugement
par contre ce que tout le monde sait
c'est qu'il y a une probabilité infime
teddy mal qu'il y ait simultanément
panne sur ses deux moteurs et aussi ce
que il faut dire c'est que ce qui fait
la force et la réputation et le succès
de ce moteur cfm56 c'est précisément ses
performances et sa fiabilité
les moteurs vont être acheminées dans
les prochaines heures dans des
laboratoires afin d'être examiné deux
éléments importants restent à étudier la
boîte noire et le témoignage du pilote
rescapé